Here's another equation for you to solve. And the ones we've been working with
have definitely gotten gradually more complex, so this one is another step up.
We have 3 times the quantity times 2 to 3t minus 2, plus 6 equals 15. Now you
could approach this equation in the exact the same way as when we did just
before this. You'll just have a few more steps at the end to reach the
solution. Now, you might want to take a couple seconds right now and pause the
video to try solving all the way to t on your own. If you feel like that might
be a little bit much, let's go through it in a slightly more step-by-step
manner. Now of course, there are many different ways to solve this problem, and
I'm just going to show one of them. First, we're going to treat 2 to the 3t
minus 2 as our variable. So, we write the equation isolating 2 to the 3t minus
2 on this side. If 2 to the 3t minus 2 seems like something sort of complicated
to work with, and sort of weird to think about as a variable, then you can
substitute in another letter, like u for instance, in place of this whole
thing. Then just solve for u.